in this video we're going to be talking
about how you can find the units for
your rate constant k
so the two things that you should know
before we get started are that one
rate constant k has units
so
this isn't always true of constants in
chemistry
but it is true of k
the second thing to remember is that
your rate constant the units
of k depend
on your on your rate law
and so we're going to use
this second point
to use the rate law to derive the units
of k
and this is really handy because that
means you don't have to memorize what
the units of k are for different orders
of reactions
so we're going to focus on the three
most common
rate laws that you see in chemistry
class
so we're going to talk about zeroth
first
and second order reactions
and we will divide uh we will
derive their units
so first let's look at zeroth order so
zeroth order reactions
have a rate law that look like this
so the rate is equal to k
times your the concentration of your
reactant a to the zeroth order
and anything to the zero or sorry to the
zeroth power
and anything to the zeroth power
is just one
so our rate is equal to the rate
constant k the units of rate are always
going to be the same so the units of
rate are always molar per second and you
can also just think of units almost like
numbers if you have an equal sign the
units on both sides of your equal sign
have to be the same and they have to
match
so here since we have rate
equal to k that means k has to also have
units of molars per second so this tells
us that the units for a zeroth order
reaction are molar per second we can use
that same idea to figure out the units
of k for first and second order
reactions too so for a second order
sorry for a first order reaction
so for first order
a first order reaction rate law is rate
is equal to the rate constant k
times the concentration of our reactant
raised to the first power units of rate
are molar per second and the units of
concentration are always going to be
molar so now we know that the units of k
times molar equals molar per second
so we have molar on both sides so we
don't have to worry about that but we're
missing a one over a second term
so that tells us that the units of k are
one over seconds
the other way we can try to figure out
the units here if you're not comfortable
with sort of back calculating what the
units are is we can actually rearrange
this rate law
so if we just put k on on one side and
everything else on the other side we get
that k is equal to rate
divided by the concentration of a
so all i did was divide both sides here
by the concentration of a
and since we know that the units on both
sides of the equal sign have to be the
same
then we can figure out the units of k
by dividing the units of rate by the
units of our concentration so that's
just molar per second
for the rate
divided by molar
for the concentration
and then the molar cancels out and we're
left with one over seconds
so that's an even more straightforward
way to find the units of k
but the idea is the same you can treat
units the same way you treat numbers and
you just have to make sure they match on
both sides of your equal sign the last
example we're going to go through is
going to be for second order reactions
so second order reactions
or second order rate laws
have the form rate is equal to our rate
constant k
times the concentration of our reactant
to the second power so on one side we
have molar per second for the rate and
on the other side now
since our concentration is squared
we have molar squared
so molar squared times something is
equal to molar per second
we need to
add a one over seconds in our units for
k because we need to make sure when we
multiply these we get the seconds on the
bottom
and we need to cancel out one of these
concentration terms so we need to put
molar in the denominator as well
so the units of k for a second order
reaction
are one over molar
molar
seconds
so these are the three most common
molecularities that you might see in a
chemistry class
and sometimes you have reactions that
aren't zeroth first or second order
and whenever that happens you can always
use the rate law to find the units of
the rate constant k